yeah to follow up on those millennial
parents um i think i feel like there's a
few things at play here first of all
there's more single parents than ever
before and i feel like millennials have
become more willing to embrace that and
another video that i saw from libs from
tick tock who's doing an extraordinary
job and probably one of the most
influential people in our parts of of
the political space but it was this one
mother in a dressing room with her child
you guys know what i'm talking about
with this dress and at the end of every
sentence she would say she would just be
like right you love this dress right
like you picked out this dress right
like you feel good you want to buy this
dress they make fun of you at school you
know they make fun of me too and then it
like pans to herself and it's her
smirking so it's like a lot of these
sing i don't know if she's a single
parent but it's a lot of these single
parents these millennial people
projecting their beliefs onto their
children and it was a non-binary looking
type millennial mother and they were
just so willing to experiment and also
like this idea that wearing dresses
makes you a girl
and like a child would understand that
as a concept that wearing a dress makes
you think you somehow want to transition
to a girl is so crazy and unfathomable
unless you project so much of your
gender ideology onto this childhood
crazy also i mean if she's not a single
parent that father should be
unbelievably ashamed i mean functionally
she is i just i just want to say
um
i feel
i feel bad for people who didn't have
two parents i i mean that genuinely i
know i know people who were in
single-family homes and i'm just like
the people that i knew who grew up with
just their dad or just their mom and
their parents are good people trying
really really hard they they did not
have that uh two-parent privilege we'll
call it it's twice as much time twice
the income
it's it's uh learning how to bake
cookies with your mom it's playing ball
with your dad or playing ball with your
mom and making cookies with your dad
maybe your dad's a famous chef or baker
maybe your mom's a sports manager or you
know in the in business or she's a
stay-at-home mom who's giving you
individualized attention and caring for
you i remember
you know just the the it's i could not
imagine not having a mom and a dad you
know how high is a talk about black
americans
and their family destructions and caused
their kids no role models and home no
debts live on welfare you know i heard
it's like 70 percent of
you know black family households are led
just by single mothers where are their
fathers and there were those role models
for their children their their those
young boys they they
they're stuck in inner schools and they
have no way to get quality education
because democrats control the school
district do not allow school choice
and then they get a board and they have
no interest school they become against
and they get arrested and thrown into
jail for years and years it's horrible
but they don't talk about this when they
talk about black lives matter let's talk
about the course of their poverty and
their high crime rate the the opposition
to school choice is is one of the most
shocking things to me because
i'm confused you've got a low income
neighborhood of any race
and the parents are like we have no
choice but to send our kids to a
low-income school with low-income
teachers with no resources with school
choice they could literally just go to
the next town over which may be
wealthier and be like we choose this
school
and then that money goes to the school
the school gets bigger and the good
schools then grow and can bring in the
lower income kids into the better
schools
why do they why do they oppose that well
because lots of teachers unions opposed
to it so when people say oh you know and
we we're really very concerned for the
people of color well in democrat country
cities states
they are in the pockets of teachers
unions and who donate lots of money for
their elections right and the teachers
union you see how they behave during the
kobe they want to use the school
reopening as a negotiation
and condition to say you okay they're
not going to come back to school until
we get what we want in los angeles it's
all marx's agenda exactly
i mean it's such an incredibly powerful
union because they can literally keep
your children hostage they say well
we're not going to be giving them an
education unless you meet our demands
and it's really unfortunate because i
you know i am not against collective
bargaining i think unions can be great
the teachers unions are not if they are
the perfect example of how it can
absolutely become the case that a union
just ends up being an organization which
protects the weaker workers from the
better workers who would outperform them
and receive more promotions and so when
you see them opposing school choice my
thought is these teachers are constantly
complaining about lower wages well
wouldn't it be the case
that if we had school choice
and educational institutions had to
compete for students they would also
have to compete for good teachers so
that they can ensure a decent
educational quality and get kids to go
there so if you are a good teacher
school choice isn't a threat because
good schools will want you and you'll
have more options as well outside of the
public school system give you example
d.c teachers union shut down the very
popular charter school in d.c because
all the black families and children they
are waiting long lines to get into this
charter school
but they shut that down do they really
care about people of color like they
claim and they're trying to teach
critical race theory into all 14 000
school districts say that you're
oppressed if you're people of color but
do you really care about people of color
to strive to get out of poverty except
sitting there being pressed and say well
victims if you really care about them
then you got to lift them up by having
educational choice for parents for kids
i feel very strongly about it it's my
top three issues defend the parental
rights and parental choice otherwise you
know those kids are stuck in the inner
poor performing schools and there's no
competition and you can throw all the
money you want to from taxpayers edit
and they do not improve in terms of
testing schools you know testing schools
and quality education at the same time
they're taught oh equity equity so
government gave me some how do they take
a personal responsibility to become like
entrepreneurs become good in maths and
readings and science and they're
competing with other country kids for
lots of good jobs right now but instead
they're focused on you know crap they're
teaching school moreover the way that
they're saying that they're helping
these students are actually hurting it's
coming at the cost of other students so
a lot of ways that they're saying
they're helping black and brown people
in these communities is by getting rid
of the upper class classes the honor
classes because they say that it
racially divides children because more
and white asian tend to be in the honors
classes and therefore if we see any you
know not a direct reflection of
population in class sizes and how it's
distributed it's automatically racist so
what do they say they just get rid of
the honors classes and then they say
they're helping everybody but really it
just comes at the cost of our our best
students that's why china like asian
americans families are geared moving
into more and more voting for
republicans because they value education
they value their kids and quality of
their education now they say all this
stuff oh my case the ap class is
cancelled and also 18 children when
they're trying to apply for harvard yale
they get discriminated because there's a
quarters
they're too excellent you cannot go if
we you know you have to wait at the
bottom of the line once the quarters is
gone and the doj dropped the lawsuit
against yale when when the asian parents
assumed yale to say your discriminatory
girls are against our kids based on skin
color because they aging but instead of
look at the individual meritocracy which
this country is supposed to be and the
left words say oh you ages are too rich
oh it's for the class economical class
it's a classical marxist theory it's oh
we have highest income in the country
than white so now in washington state if
you're 18 children you're supposed to go
to the white group because you
you make too much money
yeah absolutely i think part of this is
a symptom of how completely economically
illiterate the left is so it seems to me
as if they more or less see the economy
as something which serves us by giving
people busy work
to keep them focused on other things all
day they don't actually understand how
supply chains work that's part of why
they they had no apprehensions about
shutting the entire economy down they
don't understand where goods and
services really come from and the fact
that the work people do in our economy
is important and so they will look at
any particular field and they'll say hmm
we need to make sure that this is
equitable we need to make sure that we
see a perfect demographic breakdown of
the population here otherwise it's
unfair instead of going oh well given
that the purpose of an economy is to
deliver goods and services these people
are in this field because they found
their way there because they're best at
doing it and maybe it is better for us
to have people who are good at jobs do
them instead of shoehorning people into
positions or out of them based on their
ethnic identity and one more thing i
want to mention is the left has
constantly claimed that they are the
party and ideology of education and
higher learning firstly they have flat
out lied about that for years they've
claimed that uh we're constantly
slashing funding for education it's
literally not true federal spending per
pupil has increased every single year
since 1970 test scores have not
increased and by the way that's an
increase in funding adjusted for
inflation as well and so
with all this extra money we've been
spending on education at the federal
level what are they doing like you said
cutting gifted classes giving fewer
children opportunities to excel
it's sickening it's interesting because
we keep hearing about this potential
asian backlash against the democratic
party but i don't know if it's ever come
to fruition because these cases against
like yale and harvard have been going on
it for i feel like almost a decade now
we're also seeing hate crimes towards
asians in a lot of different communities
that we're waiting to see this backlash
from also on the education front but i
i don't know
what percentage of the united states is
asian i think it's relatively small but
in certain areas they have
i think they're um gathered around the
coasts mostly so in specific areas they
might have outsized influence as i
understand in new york city and
chinatown asians are the chinese
specifically are some of the least
politically involved um and they refuse
they don't refuse to vote but they just
don't and it's interesting because
there's a lot of reasons for that the
system that they came from in china
obviously they didn't have the
opportunity to vote in the past also
there's this language barrier that
exists still in a lot of these chinese
immigrant communities so there's a lot
of seven percent seven percent seven
percent
new hampshire is uh asian americans is
three percent but it is the second
largest minority group
so i'm not sure that the democrats are
worried about seven percent when we when
they were talking about uh bill maher
was talking about student debt
forgiveness bill maher said 13 of
americans have student debt not a large
group
and he's outright saying like why why
would we be focused on this 13 well
asians are seven i certainly think the
democrats don't care
i've mentioned this on the show many
times when i was younger i was told
never to check asian off on any form and
ask my from ask for my race because i
was told you will be discriminated
against based on the assumptions they
make about asians so you're better off
just putting you know white down or
something but they use us when they want
to advance their agenda called stop
aging hate right you know white are
racist white supremacists are taking
agents according to doj data 2018 most
crimes happened against the agents you
know what there are people of color
yeah i think asians are all so scared to
talk about this one rep his name is john
liu
in lower manhattan i've spoken to him
about this and what did he say when he
was trying to address these hate crimes
he was telling me about like education
classes i also think there's an issue
here with influential asian people in
the culture in media unwilling to call
out this crime specifically because
they're scared to get labeled because
they're scared to get labeled racist and
um yeah it's it's a sad fact a reality
well it's uh it's very sad for me i have
been telling people
i see similarities between mouse culture
revolution and with what's going on in
today's america and in instead we use a
you know classes here just use races
it's everything's about race everything
is about your skin color instead of your
diversity of ideas and thoughts
personality and skills and knowledge
right i will i love diversity like you
said you know we are part of diversity
but they only talk about diversity of
the skin color which is which is wrong
and also well not only that they only
talk about diversity of skin color when
they consider it to be uh advantageous
to them or diversity of ethnicity when
it's advantageous to them we were just
mentioning the fact that they want fewer
asian students in universities and you
mentioned the asian hate that there's
hate crimes against asians well this is
just the inevitable byproduct of
critical theory as applied to race when
you spend decades telling the black
community that the white community is
only successful only doing well because
they have stolen something from you that
instills in the psyche of the general
public that if any group of people is
outperforming another group of people it
is because they have victimized that
group so the inevitable conclusion from
that kind of logic is that asian people
have cheated in some way so the
expectation is that we would see more
crimes against them it's difficult it's
an insane ideology based on greed and
envy and it is to blame for these hate
crimes there's no question about it you
know what's really funny
that there are stereotypes and tropes
about asian parents
you watch any comedy show and the asian
parent is demanding of their of their
kid to get better grades you know a
futurama uh i had the joke i think you
should trauma
on me there's there's what they call
positive discrimination stereotype
against asians that the asian parent is
a strict academic and then all of a
sudden they're like how can asians make
more money we should we should
imagine this
your parents are strict and tell you to
work hard study hard and get in the best
school so the school says make it harder
so what what's what's the outcome then
the parents should be like it doesn't
matter if you work hard because the
school's not going to let you in anyway
and then once the scores start dropping
they'll be like ah okay now we can let
them back in because they're not doing
as well
it's insane they're saying is though and
and traditionally culturalize that the
aging parents always value education
because that's the only way they can get
out poverty look at the chinese people
who come from china like me who started
with nothing and because of the
education the skill the degree we got we
get a good jobs we start on business we
work their butt off and to achieve
american dream we're not rich we have no
connection in this country we have no
social status we have no inheritance
money in this country it is a hard work
ethics make us successful and you i have
seen parents from china running
restaurants look how hard work that is
seven days a week no vacations they send
their kids thousand dollars a year to
harvard and now there's like
oh my kids cannot get in no matter how
high their act is and now you would take
act might be racist now this is this is
a question i i would love to see it is
by the way we have the trope of we have
the trope of the student going to
college and then coming back with their
head shaved and purple hair what would
happen to a kid who's in an asian family
the asian parents are very strict saying
you better score really high in sats
you're going to go to harvard and then
they score really really well and
they're wearing like a suit a tie and
they they go off to the university and
then come home to their asian family
with their head shaved purple hair and
they're wearing like cut off sleeves and
like sweatpants like whatever dad i
don't care anymore call me janet
i want to mention you said that
something about the acts there are sats
there are people who consider the sats
and acts to be racially biased so they
are considered racist as well you know
i'm a wonderful disparity
that exists
but here's something you might not know
canceling academic
achievement excellence is what mao did
during china's cultural revolution one
guy
after cultural revolution like a school
reopen he was taking a test
and he said i don't care about this i'm
going to turn in my test blank so he got
a big zero right guess what he's a
glorious they made him a hero
and his name is donkey and i remember
that very well so now i'm saying the
same thing happened in this country
castling individual
excellence
in academic in science in art economic
issues
can you say why i'm warning people this
is a cultural revolution happening in
america yeah it's scary stuff tim you
mentioned how um a lot of these asian
immigrants uh parents are sending their
kids to college they're coming back
head-to-head i'm not saying they are i'm
saying i'm i wonder what that like it's
one thing if you're a liberal you know
american and your kid comes back and
they're they're doing all these things
and they believe all this weird stuff
and these liberals are going to be like
oh very progressive of you honey but for
like a strict conservative asian parent
for that to happen to their kids they
might be like what i'm not saying this
isn't the exact same thing but i want to
draw a parallel but the cultural
revolution was actually led by the youth
right in in china's right
where all the youth in the schools that
were the leaders of this so that same
parallel that we're seeing in the
universities that happened in china we
are seeing to some degree here as well
because kids are going to college
becoming more indoctrinated coming back
to their home and the parents don't
understand what their kids but they
don't know the history that's what i'm
saying they even don't know they were
some of them praise it i know people who
think what's happening in china and
what's happened in the past is a good
thing i know people online on twitter i
feel like it's easy to find people
denying that the
tiananmen square massacre even happened
so we do nursing homes oh wow that uh if
you were in this country even deny that
it's like uh we should shoot them a tank
man
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there